anyways uh we're gonna switch to a new
lecture this is this is the first time
the lecture series has been given it
used to be understanding practical chess
but they are like josh you don't
actually understand practical chess we
can't have you teach this course
so they changed it
uh no i'm kidding obviously it wasn't
because of me uh they just wanted to mix
things up so it's now called double
x-clam
which is basically
games that feature i don't know why i
keep doing this a games that feature um
double x clam moves
so i usually would pick games of like
top players or from the past
i actually decided that
i would choose a few of my own games you
don't often get to play double x clan
moves at least in my experience uh you
can give these moves generously like
double x glam like what does it mean
right like an exclamation mark moves a
move that's clearly best and is best is
like difficult a little bit right like
best for a very particular reason
uh like when you need a very decisive
move double x claim i feel like
chess definitions are not clear all the
time
but i would say the double x glam means
that there's like a little bit of
inspiration behind it like really
unexpected so a move that
is not only very very strong but maybe
and strongest but also there's a little
bit of inspiration a little bit of like
wow where'd that move come from so
that's how i see double x climb moves
and that's kind of how i'm treating it
so i i haven't played that many at least
that i would label that in my career
um
so
i
decided i'd show a few
uh so let me go to my study here
all right
so uh let me go toward this position
uh i don't know i would say double x
then moves would have to be the best
move in the position like if it's not
the best move i wouldn't give a double f
slam everyone's different i would say
people annotate
differently for example if you read a
nun end game book which i'd recommend
they're very difficult but they're
really precise like john nunn will say
that like most people don't do it this
way but for me x-clam means a move that
is an only move like to only move to cat
to to get that result so for example if
you're up a pawn in a rook in game an
glen move may be the only move that wins
so that's what he would give an x-clam
i'm not quite so strict
but i would say that x-clams in general
i would give only for
um
i would give x clams only for like
clearly good moves that are
like like important and double x clam
i'd say like there's an element of
either something that's beautiful about
it or
unexpected things like this so i'm going
to actually show you two different
examples um three technically but
so this was actually in 2005 i played
this game 16 years ago now wow
that's actually crazy to think about
almost 17 years this game was played
almost 17 years ago
at the fox woods open in connecticut at
the casino i was black against ilya
schneider
oh my goodness it wasn't illegitimate it
was igor schneider
how did i do that
igor schneider
who was at the time he was an fm
and i think i was an im at the time
something like this anyways uh or maybe
even fm
uh so
yeah definitely the chess.com algorithm
and again it's really cool that they can
design an algorithm at all so i'm not
really saying it's bad but
definitely a lot of those double x
claims are very dubious like not that
it's not the best move but that why
would you give this move a double s plan
so we all have this anyway this i
actually got to play this move uh in a
tournament and i was very very happy
with it so i wanted to give you guys
a couple like just double xclam moves i
was able to play and then one game which
i think contains a double x-clam move
but also just to show
how spectacular things work kind of so
black to play
find the double x glam move
oh something fell that was good
uh it was d6 uh honey
so again i'm looking at the chat for
some answers uh again i mean it's
kind of good and i would say that this
position what's really funny is
originally i was just gonna play rookie
six and just double rooks and say well
your bishop's on a2 and my position's
dominating like you know why do i have
to do anything special
but when you see a move like this you
kind of have to play it
and i would say this finding the move is
one part of the challenge but the second
part of the challenge is calculating the
whole line to get a winning position
well b4 i would be inclined not to play
unless i'm sure because like right now
my pawns do a beautiful job of keeping
this bishop out of play so i don't
really want to let the bishop get into
the game
so people have mentioned knight d1 is a
funny candidate it's definitely a very
beautiful move but what are the what's
the continuation after 91 what's like
the best continuation
um
there's a bit more to it my name is
buffalo
so you guys have the idea like what what
that move does but what about a
variation like what's a precise
variation because i would say that it's
easy sometimes to spot a spectacular
move not easy but sometimes you spot it
but the key is
like what happens afterwards like how do
you find like how do you calculate the
clear win and i'd say that's the most
important part there have been
probably far more failed spectacular
moves than successful ones so part of it
is
like again i saw this move pretty
quickly but i thought a long time before
i played it because i wanted to make
sure it was best in winning
very good honey
knight d1 is indeed the move very nice
those of you who spotted it
so
first the idea very spectacular queen c5
rook takes e1 check and knight f2 mate
not not a mating pattern you see every
day but a very very cool spot mate and
even nicer is after rook takes e1 rook
takes eight this doesn't even help white
because after queen takes c5
check
and that's made down a whole queen but
that's checkmate
so to me that's like a pretty cool
tactic but you're not done after rook
takes the e8 rook takes the eight white
can play the move queen at one
and what's really funny is after knight
f2 check king g1 there's no really great
discovered check
i could take this pawn on b2 i suppose
but that doesn't look so special
so if i don't have anything great here
this isn't so wonderful right
like it's great to be able to play
knight d1 and you feel good with
yourself but if after queen f1 you don't
have a win you're like hmm
but the question is what does black's
win after queen f1
taking the b2 pawn is probably good
enough but
uh i don't know i mean
probably it's probably it's fine right
like you probably win that position but
i think there's a bit better
very good
rookie one
so pinning the queen of the king they
must take a noun out of two check so of
course queen takes f2 is possible giving
up the queen he played this i played
knight d3 check hitting the king and the
queen
and this position after takes takes i
think i played king f8 or g6 or
something and
after this it's very very easy to
to claim victory because the bishop is
still out of the game and in the
meantime i'm just going to move around
and start taking stuff so he really
doesn't have much a chance to
you know to to save this game so
overall kind of a cool tactic but knight
d1 i would say is an example of a really
spectacular move
so i'm actually going to give you one
that's slightly easier
um but it's one which i would definitely
call a double x-clam move and i'll tell
you why
so this was a game i played
at the moscow open in 2008 against
this tournament was brutal guys like
it's kind of like
like now you play in tournaments and
everyone seems underrated when i played
in moscow
there were several really strong players
but even the players who were lower
rated than me were so good
um i mean i think i had this 2300 kid
grind me down in some technical end game
with like perfect technique and it's
like wow it's just a different world
but overall my tournament was kind of
so-so not great i
you know
about broke even on rating something
like that maybe lost a little bit but
this last game was fun to play so
i actually had a choice earlier about
whether to trade the rooks and trading
the rooks would have won but i felt like
it was messy
and i calculated this very very long
variation
and it ended up in this position so my
opponent who is in slight time trouble
thought i blundered he played rook g2
check and took defending the pawn on g7
from mate
um
but yeah i can tell a couple of you see
it already
but at the end you kind of miss what you
call like a i forget who told me this
it's the stinger at the end of the tail
right like you're looking at a
scorpion's tail and then
uh the stinger at the end and the whole
point is that you see a whole variation
except the last move and the last move
changes the whole position
because it looks like i blundered
horribly i'm up a piece still but black
has tons of counter play
yes queen takes g7 check
very very cool move to be able to play
knight f6 check and what's really what i
love about this position i actually
showed this to a kids uh
group who i was showing checkmates to
earlier today what i love about this
position is that this rook is essential
if this rook weren't here black would
just be winning after kg7
but because after king h8 rook check
this rook is actually in the way
so it has to block on the worst square
possible and allow meat
so queen takes g7 check was a very very
cool move to be able to play and this
was actually the last run of the
tournament so i got to finish the
tournament on a high note even though on
the whole it was not so great
um
luckily i was able to play better in
aeroflot open which took place right
after um nothing spectacular but i had a
pretty solid tournament i felt like
i broke even on raiding in russia and i
felt like i've had to play well to do
like the players are just very strong
um
i remember i played one kid and he was
rated 2200 and i won but it was tough
and then i saw he was a gm like less
than two years later or something i was
like wow it's they're a lot better than
i was at that time let me put it that
way um
but anyway it was a cool experience
uh so the next one
i'm gonna actually show you a whole game
so this one uh in this game i am black
let me just actually check something
here all right great
just want to make sure it's not showing
the notes uh this one i was black uh
against reuben felgaer who's an
argentinian gm
this game was played in 2011 uh i
believe at the continental championships
this took place in mexico it was the
second to last round so we were both
kind of towards the
leaders so if whoever won this game
would have a good shot to qualify for
the world cup
so it was a really really important game
and this game i wanted to show because
i want to show one way like sometimes
spectacular moves come when you're
crushing your opponent you find some
double exclam move but i would say a lot
of the really
a lot of the double exclamations that
come about actually come out of
necessity and i'll show you why so
i'm going to breeze through the opening
it was a lopez
i decided to play marshall which i don't
didn't usually play but
i prepared very specifically
so he plays bishop b3 this is all pretty
standard takes takes knight a5 i play
knight c4 and c5
he plays b3 knight b6 again this is all
relatively normal
net fd7
knight bd2
rooks
why josh do you do this
rook c8s queen b1
the game fast forwarded real fast
and he played this move queen b1 and
stood up from the board and this move
shocked me i remember that
thinking what are you doing like this
this unbeating maneuver looks very
strange but it doesn't make sense the
the pin is annoying and he wants to try
to get his pieces out
so i thought a long time here and i came
up with maybe the worst possible
solution on how to play the position um
so i want you guys to all to find a way
to play for black and i almost guarantee
you'll play it better than i did i found
maybe the worst possible idea
and it's it's bad because i think
strategically it was a bit dubious but i
also think that tactically it is also
bad so
just find any good idea for black and
you'll be fine
no this puzzle is more just getting you
into the game like you you're faced with
this queen b1 move how would you react
to it i would say it's a bit clever
though because i would love to play like
i would love normally they do stuff like
this with a bishop here and then i can
at least put my bishop on g6 to kind of
dull this bishop on c2
so c4 would be a perfectly good move
here probably the best move uh the idea
is you're threatening c3 so they take
so in the game i didn't like this
because after bc4 bishop c3 my
position's very cramped and not so good
but i can take with the knight and take
him with the knights pretty strong
actually
so allowing these two pawns in the
center is sometimes dubious but here
i have some pressure on these knights i
have activity i think i'd be doing okay
overall
so c4 would be a good move um
c takes d4 i didn't love because after
knight takes my bishop's not great still
better than what i played
and even bishop h5 here just a tempo
down trying to play bishop g6 is
perfectly fine
um
it's not perfect like it definitely
white has some advantage after bishop h5
but
it's it's fine
so i came up with i thought a long time
and came up with a strategic concept
here
my concept was that after bishop takes
knight pawn takes pawn takes d4
uh
the whole idea is that after he captures
i was gonna play g6 and basically play
against this bishop i get rid of my own
bishop which i thought was dead weight
and now i'm going to play against the c2
bishop
so the question is what is the flaw to
my logic what did what move did he drop
down on me here
very good
e5 is a very strong move after knight
takes d4 g6 even here i'm probably worse
but at least my idea would make some
sense because
i'm trying to take the dark squares and
make this bishop not so good i guess he
can still play rookie 2 queenie 1 bring
his other rook out and he's still
probably better but at least it's
playable for me
but he drops down e5
and now i realize that wait a second
something has gone very
wrong
this isn't supposed to happen i can take
this pawn right but now after bishop h7
check
knight takes e5 all of a sudden my king
is just wide open and i realized this
was awful for me
so i played the move g6
the question is what move does he drop
down on me now and again i would give
this up this move also an x-clan by him
no double x comes left we'll get to that
in a bit
very good e6
again
and now it's like oh no and i was like
at the board just kind of like this
going am i just gonna it's gonna be like
this is a crucial game
in this tournament and i'm just gonna
lose like a potzer
i'm gonna get crushed by him he's gonna
get a brilliancy prize they're gonna
award it he'll be standing up there with
his brilliancy prize give a great speech
i was having nightmares
um
now i wasn't actually thinking all that
at the time but i was definitely like i
definitely realized something had gone
wrong i was very very nervous here
but i did the only thing i could do i
played pawn takes pawn i thought that
was the best tray
at least make him prove what he has
and it also gives him a choice
and i saw a glimmer of hope because i i
had a slight inspiration as to what my
idea would be here but it was very vague
but i definitely had a hope so he has
two moves both of which look absolutely
crushing bishop takes g6 and knight
takes d4
the question is which one would you guys
play and which one do you think is
better
in any reasons right like you can say
the move if you want but if you give a
variation or reasons behind it it's even
better so what do you guys think
well i don't think he wants to secure a
draw i think he wants to destroy me so
i wouldn't worry about that
so we got a lot of bishop g6 people
uh i don't know what exchange size
sacrifice you're talking about after an
84 like rook c2 is probably not great
keep in mind he's a gm himself i think
he was rated about 50 points higher than
me and white so i don't think drawing me
is something he would take great pride
in but
we were relatively close in raiding like
not that far apart but
and keep in mind a draw would leave us
in a difficult position a win would put
us in a position where we really like
had you know chances to do something in
the tournament
so bishop takes g6 would indeed be
winning here
i would even give this move maybe 2x
clams although it's expected it's kind
of like the most natural move so maybe
not
but this move would be crushing first of
all if i take he simply takes and rook
takes e6
and my king is just completely trashed
the the d4 pawn's falling next he's
threatening mate in a million different
ways this is not good so i wasn't really
considering taking it
uh there were two moves i was
considering one was e5
and here takes h7 king h8
there's one key kind of idea here
which is very important
so how would you try to beat me here as
white because this was one defense i was
considering it doesn't work but it was
one i was considering
okay
so knight g5 i think i can take that
uh rookie four is definitely possible
um
again though i don't have to take the
bishop so i might and you're not
threatening rook h4 so i might have an
opportunity to play like knight d5
getting my knight in
i don't know
it's definitely a
a very interesting move though
knight d4 is possible uh i don't see the
mate though after i take it
like if takes i can play bishop f6 maybe
i don't know if i'm getting mated maybe
i am but
so queen g6 is kind of what i would
count on here
so there is something very cool uh the
question actually this is a good
question what is the best move for black
here
let's just make sure i remember this
right
yeah so knight f6
uh looks very nice but there's a big
problem with it actually
so queen eight allows queen uh if you
play queen et i can play queen h6 and
this is going to be crushing you
so knight f6
uh rook cheats
um
ah so here rook g8
i think still here is good
maybe
uh i could also take this rook i i think
is also probably very strong
uh so knight f6 though what is the issue
it's actually quite nice
so knight g5 i don't know if it works
let me check this out actually
maybe here i can play this move with the
idea of queen h6 knight g4
and if queen
yeah and then i can take this knight
yeah this might work
because i'm hitting your queen you don't
have time for anything
so knight g5 i think doesn't quite work
the the key is actually this move knight
takes d4
because now if pawn takes d4 bishop
takes d4 the problem is i'm just getting
made it every which way because this pin
so for example if here you can even play
something like this
and if rope takes then mates yeah
stupid pin right
so this would be terrible so i'd have to
try 1967 and then 96 so threatening mate
and the queen
i have to try this hitting his queen and
then i forget where the queen goes if
it's f7 or h6 let me see ah yeah h6
system
and then the whole idea is rook takes
pawn is coming too potentially
so for example the queen probably has to
go like say queen e8 for example
rook takes e5 is just completely
crushing something like this
so i guess ah there's still bishop f8 i
forgot about this move i'm cheating a
little bit but
yeah but the problem is that even when
you go for this
i kind of lose all my pawns and this is
not exactly a pleasant position
but yeah bishop g8 is very neat
however in this position i can play them
with rook takes f3 first
and now knight f6
and now because there's no sacrifice
here this is actually quite okay for
black i think
so queen g6 is what i was hoping for but
at some point i realized that after just
bishop back
i'm basically dead
because
he's just coming in with all these
resources and like my pieces are tied up
and he can sack at some point like my
pawns are not gonna hold in the center
so just bringing the bishop back rather
than queen g6 is just very strong
sometimes the simple moves are very good
i was considering rook takes f3 might be
the best move but even here after check
and takes it's not so great
i can play bishop f6 for instance
rook takes e6
knight f8 so i have to give a little bit
of material back
but this kind of position is just really
not good uh the two bishops are
monstrous here and
my king is wide open
like king h1 queen h3 rook g1 this is
just gonna be very very sad so bishop
takes g6 would have been absolutely
crushing and he probably would have
destroyed me if he played this move but
i think he actually thought that he had
no need to even do that i think he
thought knight takes d4 he's threatening
knight takes e6 he's threatening bishop
takes g6 my old position's in ruins and
it's simple like what is he gonna miss
right
and this is where i'd say
a lot of like brilliancies you can call
them i wouldn't even call them that but
like really like spectacular ideas are
born
it's born out of necessity i'm getting
destroyed so
i need a way to not get destroyed here
so i looked i looked at every kind of
random tempo move i could i looked for
all sorts of crazy ideas and i found a
crazy idea
um
so again rook takes c2 looks nice but it
doesn't really solve any problems right
like rook takes c2
i think he just takes and 96 is still
coming like i'm i'm still getting killed
that's kind of the problem so rook takes
c2 doesn't solve enough problems
so the the double x-clan move that i
would call it at least doesn't come for
a few moves but i kind of saw it at this
point
so you're very close uh plo crow
so
bishop h4 is how it starts
so at first this move looks kind of
silly but the idea is that bishop takes
f2 is not so great if you allow it
so for example if knight takes c6 bishop
f2 king here bishop e1 and this is a key
idea i cover i threaten mate
so they have to take the bishop and then
queen e7 and i'm pinning this guy i'm
threatening this bishop
uh i'm actually doing very well
so knight takes e6 would be very bad
rook takes e6
it's interesting but after bishop takes
f2
i can take this knight play queen here
hitting the bishop
i'm kind of surviving
uh it's not so easy but
uh and bishop takes g6 is also very
promising but after check e5 again i
kind of am living
if 96 i go here i sack the exchange
i actually think this is like
plenty of chances for me
so he plays though the obvious move
which is g3
and here it's kind of like well josh
what exactly have you accomplished
you just put a bishop on a hanging
square
but i promise you i had an idea
so one of you mentioned queen f6 this
move is actually
often like a decent idea trying to hit
f2 the problem is that often this move
f4 is really annoying
so there's a very very similar line to
this like yeah here f4 i think is a big
problem
and there's just no way to to deal with
this like if e5 i just go back
and i'm just gonna take your bishop it's
kind of sad actually
so queen f6 would be nice e5 is possible
but then after knight e6 queen f6 i take
your rook so like if here
um
knight e6 if queen f6
i think yeah i take your rook
and i think i can just defend this guy
now right
but maybe f4 is still a decent move i
don't know but like something like
rookie two i don't really see where my
compensation is
oh we have it
so this is where the double x-clam move
comes in
i have my rook my queen and my bishop
hanging
and one of the nice things when you have
a lot of pieces hanging is that you
don't actually have to defend them all
the time because they can only take one
piece at a time
so i say have my most valuable piece
so rook takes f2 i'd give a double x
clam first of all it's definitely
clearly the best move in my only chance
but part of it also was i had to kind of
see this back when because in this
position if i don't have rook takes f2
i'm just dead
so
not only is it best but it's probably
the only idea
it's not enough to necessarily save the
game like i think white's still better
if they play very accurately
but it's by far the best try and
definitely
um
a decent idea uh and it's again i would
say it has the extra x-clam for being
spectacular not only is it a queen sack
but it just seems to come out of nowhere
um but again keep in mind this wasn't
born out of well i'm crushing my
opponent and let me sack some stuff it's
like well i'm desperate and
i either do this or resign or give up
all my pieces right so it's like
sometimes you just have to find great
moves or you just lose and
i would say that here i managed to find
this resource but
another day who knows right
uh and it definitely makes things very
very complicated
um and it was one of those moves where
he was thinking a very long time and
you could tell like there were people
passing by the board and just looking at
it like wait what is going on
so my opponent actually plays it very
accurately at first and i would say that
this is to his credit it's very easy to
freak out when you see a move like rook
takes f2 it comes out of nowhere and
like what's going on
but
you know the really good players even if
they're faced with moves like this will
come up with good moves so first of all
if he tries to decline the queen sack
and take my rook i can simply play queen
f6 check
and here i think it's just a draw with
best play i take the knight he probably
has to take my bishop and i just keep
checking him
and this is even he's up a rook but he
can't ever cross the f file due to rook
f1 check
so this is simply a draw
um
so his only try is to take the queen
i take on c2 and here once again he
finds the best continuation for white so
what would you guys try to do with white
here i'm actually kind of curious it's
not easy facing the two rooks but you
can see my idea right i sacrificed the
queen i'm down currently a queen for a
piece that's not very much
but my two rooks on the seventh are so
strong that they actually compensate for
a queen almost fully i'm also trying to
take advantage of this queen being stuck
on b1 if any of these things weren't
true it would be
um
it would be
it would be not so great so bishop d4 is
actually the move which
i thought was the best try during the
game
um but it turns out i'm actually okay
after this
uh so yeah of course if he wants to he
can simply play ponte's bishop and we
just draw not like that that would be
checkmate
and we would probably just draw right
like here takes
here
and you know
there are lots of ways i can draw that's
not really the issue right
um so queen takes c2 is what he played i
think that's the best move this is what
worried me during the game
so here i think the most accurate way to
play is rook g2 check
so first of all if he goes to h1 i take
and now i can actually just take this
knight and believe it or not the two
pieces are better than the queen here
like
the rooks are so powerful and i have
lots of pawns and my pieces are coming
in like there's no way white can ever
think of winning this game in fact
white's in trouble i think
so you must go to f1 and you'll see why
i put the king there uh in a bit later
takes here
so one of the keys here is that if they
try to sack now
my pawn structure is worse but i have
this move knight d5 and now knight e3
check is going to be very nasty and
that's why i want the king on f1 without
with the king on g1 knight d5 is far
less strong
so that's kind of the whole point so
rookie 8 check is the best move king g7
takes here
and now
after check white should probably just
draw just take this draw
because if they try to go to e1
black has a very very strong move any
guesses
95 very nice
yeah so here they have actually only one
way to to try to play here so
um
i think rookie 7 check is the best move
if they try rook takes e5
then simply takes and if check i just go
back
and here they're actually just in
trouble because rook takes h6 is just
gonna end up in mate and if they try to
sack their queen i have too much
material now
so this position i think is simply bad
um again it's not like
you know white resigns right away but
overall like the pieces are just so much
stronger
so i don't think that works out
uh what else is there yeah there's queen
takes c2
but now i can simply take and after
rookie 7 check i can move up
and i think this position is also kind
of dead so for example if he tries to
check me
and take the pawn just for instance
i'm pretty sure
what's the way to win here
um
oh yeah i think it's like this right so
here
if
king f3 one of the things i can do is do
this and then come up and i think i have
this idea
so it takes i go here and i'm actually
just delivering mates
something like this
um oh sorry sorry sorry no no i just
take here and then there's this stuff
yeah yeah this is very strong
uh very similar actually to one of the
other lines
um so the best try is actually rookie 7
check
because now i can't really come up
because then i've checked king f5 like
i'm pinned and that's a big problem
so i have to go back
and now white has a spectacular way to
try to hold takes takes
and white only has one move really to
try to hold this
and i'll give you a hint it has to do
with having the king on f8 because if
you give black extra moves like if you
play rook here for example and i play
knight d5
you're basically dead because these
knights are going to come in and they're
going to check me too
like these knights are deadly so you
have to play exactly oops
uh where am i sorry
okay uh
kingi1995 rookie 7 check
takes takes rook c7
and the idea is that i can't take the
rook because of 96 check that's why the
king is important so i take here and now
they go for this 96 check
so if i do this they just draw and so i
don't want to draw here they do this i
give my king a little escape square
i take the rook and probably i have good
winning chances here is what i would
call it i'm up a lot of prawns it's not
so simple to win because white's so
active here
but probably i'm the one with chances so
to simplify this for you they really
should take a draw if they go for this
but i didn't see all this during the
game as you would imagine it's not so
easy to see so bishop d4 was the move i
was scared of but it turns out he
actually played the best move he took
and took the bishop very simple rook b2
and he plays rook ad one also best
d5 i have to push my pawns
knight c6 e4
and this is kind of where things get
absolutely crazy
he has a couple different tries he
played the move a4 which is actually
quite logical trying to trade off some
puns and liquidate a little bit
but after that i think i'm doing okay
so the basic deal is i have two pawns
for the exchange his pawn structure on
the king side is not great which helps
me
but i also have loose pawns for the
moment and his rooks are quite good and
i have to be careful the game doesn't
simplify too much which would help him
so the question is what would you try
here for white he has a couple different
tries apart from a4 which is what he
played
so a 97 check for sure
is one of the tries
so king g7
knight takes d5
but here black has a very very nice move
well rook c2 i don't want to allow the
trades right 95 very nice
so the idea is if he tries to take my
my knight
there's knight check and this is a draw
if he ever goes to h1 i made him with
rook h2 so this is a known drawing
technique
drawing motif
so he should not take but he does have a
very very nice way to try to continue
uh hello hello everyone uh
so rook f1 is possible but i think the
issue with it as i can take this knight
and then play check and he actually has
to sack his rook and
this is not good for him probably losing
the rook end game
so the best move is actually king f1
and now the question is how do i play as
black once again not so simple
so plot crowd that's one idea
yeah knight takes d5 doesn't really work
out because after rook d5 knight f3
you can simply play rookie two this is
kind of the issue and there's no
perpetual with the knight anymore the
rooks if the rooks trade it's very bad
uh if knight f3
i believe it's the same thing just
rookie 2 is a big problem
and it's even worse because it takes
here i think i just take this knight
and then take here
that's an extra piece even this is maybe
not so simple you take but i don't know
i feel like white's gonna win this a
pawn maybe like this is gonna be an
extra piece that's better than the puns
but even this is maybe not super simple
knight d3 is indeed the best tray
so rook takes e4 is the move if they try
to take here um
let me see what's the deal after takes i
think yeah i take
and i think it's just too many pawns now
because i can take this pawn and then
take this pawn
that's a lot of pawns and
i think it's just too liquidated like
you're just not going to be able to win
with so few puns on the board
something like
this
um
so that's kind of the issue there
so 93 rook takes e4 is the best try but
then knight f2
rookie 7 check
king f8 so everything's kind of hanging
it's a funny position
but white still has a good try here what
do you think white's good try is anyone
so rook de1 i think i can play knight
takes knight and this is probably good
for me
uh rookie two i can take your rook i
think
defending my own rook
and my knight doesn't quite get trapped
because you have to take the time to
take
also i can oh i can take your knight
but even if i had to take your rook i
can get out with knight d3 and again
with these pawns you're never going to
be better really
um
so
oh this computer probably should be
plugged in
figure that out
uh
so yeah there's another move for white
here
remember your rook's hanging right
it's okay it's a tough position and
we're not even remotely towards the end
and once again i'm not implying i saw
this like this is just like how crazy
the variations get
so it's white's move guys let's move
well there's only so many safe squares
for that rook right
so the best one is rook d4
so you're basically
playing against that knight that knight
feels a little foolish so i take here
and then that was most certainly not ben
and simon but
yes
so rookie two
so
forcing the rook off king takes
and here we have both knights hanging
but once again knights are tricky pieces
guys so one way to play is knight h3 and
i think this probably is good enough
it's a little weird though playing this
way because i feel like our knights are
not coordinated maybe they can try
something
so knight e4 is what i looked at which
is even funnier
i want to centralize my knights
so the knights defend each other in it
like because of this fork right
so either night they take this is a nice
little tactic it takes this night then
takes
um so if they have to play something
like king up and i just play knight back
i think black's doing very well with the
two knights maybe the king comes up or
something
maybe up to the center i don't know
but we're not done because they take
here
check
takes takes and their king is a lot
better than ours even though their pawn
structure is worse
so it turns out there's only one way to
draw for black
would you guys like to find
it at least i think so
only one way to draw
and keep in mind this is just the 97
check line we haven't even gotten to the
other line
so a5 i just play king d5 and just go
after your pawns
well i wouldn't play b4 right away i'd
probably go say king d5 threatening king
c6 and then after king d7 i'd play b4
and say shut out your pawns and
i don't think this is gonna go super
well
because you can't keep my king out
forever like let's say you play h6 i can
play h3 if you play here i can play here
you eventually run out of moves and then
it's not so great
so trying to play like that is going to
be tough yes douglas you have to play
king g7 and there are lots of different
nuances but the basic idea is you get
something like this
king runs king up
b4 just to prevent b4 moves from black
takes here
takes takes
g5
so you don't want to push the a pawn
because then black queen's first so you
do this and now the whole point is that
you clean with check
and if you try something like this you
lose because takes takes
a4
and this is not gonna end well we've
seen this kind of thing before
and you can't get to g1 if king here i
play here
and you lose
so let us not do this
so you actually have to keep your king
away but the advantage is you can cross
the g file because here if i try to take
this queen then i'm in time right here
a4 my queen after you do
so you take the pawn but the king is way
too open the apon's vulnerable there's
no way like
obviously you can try as white but
you're going to get checked to death
here the apon's too vulnerable the queen
on h7 is too out of play you can blunder
right if you do something like this and
play queen check and i go here then it's
like oh shoot
but as long as you check diagonally and
don't allow the queen blocks it's an
easy draw because they opposed to loose
so that doesn't work out
the other line
is a different move so instead of knight
e7 check and instead of a4 which is what
was played
um
what else can we do
this is a very clever move which i i
looked at during the game a little and
maybe fear i feared the most but i
didn't realize how good it was although
even there it turns out i have more
chances than i thought
i would say though that this move is the
best try to win for what
so see what you guys can do again i
wouldn't give it a double x plan but i'd
give it a single x plan
knight before i think's a bit too
passive
and allows knight e5 95 is a very
powerful move which really secures at
least a draw for me most of the time
so i would say not knight v4
taekwondo that seemed to come out of
nowhere
oops
and i'm not a martial arts kind of guy
myself
we're asking
yeah a4 is what was played um it turns
out the best try here for white is rook
f1
and the basic idea is that i have
nothing better really than taking this
pawn and then he plays knight e7 check
and goes for this
and again like if i try to take and take
this knight is just really terrible so
for example if knight f6 he plays here
and one sad line is if i try to activate
my knight he checks me
if king back to g8 for example here and
rook c8 is crushing
so i have to go up and then here and my
knight actually blocks me so if king h5
he takes i have to block with the knight
which of course
is awful
um
and here i'm actually lost
wow a lot of questions that are very
random i am 35 wow i'm 35 that's crazy
all right
so um
so the better move for black here is
knight e5
so i pitched this piece
check on f3 they sack but it turns out
this position is not so easy to win i
don't believe because
again this knight on b6 is a bit out of
play i have lots of pawns the doubled h
pawns don't really make life easy for
whites
i still think white has some okay
chances they play rook here so they win
the f-pawn but i give a check i go back
and then i come up the board and i kind
of take these pawns well i can play
knight d5 and b4 and have some chances
but i think that it's going to be very
difficult with all the pawns liquidating
so fast to to win as white
so i would say that black has good
drawing chances but definitely white
still has chances to win as well so
this would have been the best so as you
can see
my whole rook takes f2
brilliancy or whatever you want to call
it
was maybe good enough to draw or i'm
still worse but at least it presents
problems in a position where i basically
was getting crushed right and a lot of
games i probably would just get crushed
but he like i found one
kind of saving grace and that's maybe
enough
but one thing i would say is that
the position became harder to play for
him so even here he's completely fine
um
but after takes takes a5 it's just a
tricky position for him to play because
he um
like he wants to still win right he's
still trying to win but the more the
game progresses like
if he doesn't do anything in the next
five to ten moves and my king gets
towards the center he's gonna be the one
in trouble so he he again doesn't want
to take because of knight e5 which is
understandable he plays rook f1
um maybe he should have tried 97 check
uh oops and taking the pun but after
knight e5 again
knight f3 i think that probably this
should be enough to draw i just
have to like he doesn't have enough
pawns to try to win but he shouldn't
lose for sure he played rook f1
and rook f2 but here i thought i had
some decent chances so in the game he
actually had chances to draw for sure
um
but he played one in accuracy and
and at this point i think knight d8 was
better so he has knight f7 check as a
possible resource he played out to the
edge of the board which i thought looked
wrong and it takes
and it turns out here he can still draw
uh but he has to find a very specific
maneuver
so see if you guys can find it this
would not be at all obvious to me he
didn't find it either
but white apparently only has one way to
try to draw here otherwise he's in
trouble
and this is what i mean like this
position even if it's equal if it's like
white's fine because the doubled pawns
are so bad because i have the connected
passers he's the one who has to play
accurately because he's dealing he's
playing against the pawns and i think
playing against the pawns is harder than
playing with them
there are some positions i'd say that
are like this where it's like it's equal
but only one side can really blow it
so rook b1 is what he played which is
very logical
and one of the moves i expected but it
is not great
the problem with rook b1 is that i play
knight e6 and now he can't stop me from
doing this at some point i can play here
and go here and he actually can't stop
it
so that's kind of the issue here
so knight c4 check is possible but i
think i i simply go to e6 and his knight
has to just go back which is not really
great and it allows me to make progress
so knight c4 check doesn't do it either
it turns out and this is crazy to me he
has to play rook d4
the idea is now my knight can't move
so i have to move my other knight if i
try to go here he can simply check me
so i have to move my other knight and
now rook b4 and i don't get the chance
to put my knight on e6 so after here he
gives check and this should be enough to
draw
after something like takes takes i just
don't quite have enough because his king
can come here
but again this is really difficult stuff
like this is not at all easy and i feel
like
even i think he was getting low on time
but even if he weren't this would be
very difficult to find so
it was kind of a funny position because
definitely he was better for most of it
even after rook takes f2 but i feel like
because he didn't do enough with a
couple moves his position became more
difficult to play than mine and here i
was able to actually win pretty easily
so the game finished rook b8 knight c5
so i'm just wanting to play here what's
really funny is during in the official
notation of the game
uh they actually cut this game off early
because they couldn't read notation
apparently my handwriting is terrible or
something or there was a mistake
but luckily i was able to save it so
yeah here i actually could have played
d4 check immediately because of this and
i probably should have
because of the check so he can't take
the pawn
uh but
i played h5 which is good enough
yes i'd say that's a good way to put it
like i was in trouble most of the game i
found a really cool idea and it kept me
in the game and because of that
especially because he was of course
still trying to win it made it so that
it put him in some danger and this
position i think is just losing the the
knight and two pawns are just a lot
better and the fact that his pawn
structure is terrible just makes it
worse like if his pawn structure were
normal i'd say he has some drawing
chances because he can try to get
counter player liquidate some puns but
here
the pawn structure just makes it
impossible
so i was able to win pretty
straightforwardly
you have to be careful
but a lot of its tactics right so here i
played czech which looks at first weird
but the idea is that after king e2 i
play chuck and his rook's on a very
unfortunate square the knight's a
difficult piece to play against so he
goes back and then knight c5
i let him take the pawn he doesn't
really want it because if he tries to
take this pawn i just push and he's
gonna get queened on pretty fast
so rook c6 he played knight d3 so i'm
just trying to regroup i'm trying to go
here at some point or maybe play king f3
knight here
so he comes up with the king i play
knight e5 so defending my pawn
checks me and pins me i play d3 check
and i have lots of ways to win i decided
to come around with my king
so i'm gonna try to play king d2 on him
he plays rookie six
i play knight c4
pins and then one last little trick i
play king d4 the idea of doing this king
d2 rather he goes behind and then i play
knight here with the idea of
putting that on c2 and then pushing and
that was indeed all she wrote
and yeah i mean it was
kind of nice to
be able to insane an endgame no
uh the endgame was just the very end of
what happened the most of the action
took place earlier uh and i could i
could talk a little bit more about the
technique but honestly the technique
once the pawns start rolling is just
kind of easy because
you just slowly move your king and pawns
up and there's not too much he can do
about it but you saw how it went from
being an endgame that was kind of okay
to one that was troublesome just because
of a couple slightly inaccurate moves it
really didn't take very much
so yeah i would say that
it's always fun to look for double
s-clan moves i'd say a lot of the
examples in books and stuff like that
are
sacrifices to win right like kasparovs
against te paulo of like his his rook
sack and all of this other stuff there
were so many spectacular moves in games
like that you guys some of them may have
seen them
um and i'd say that's what a lot of them
are but sometimes you get to play double
excellent moves not because you're
crushing your opponent but because
you're getting killed because
if you don't find a double x glam move
your position falls apart and i would
say that's less common but sometimes it
can be kind of nice because
you know sometimes when your positions
flowing moves like that are spectacular
occur to you more easily but sometimes
your position is horrible and you find a
spectacular move to stay in it it's a
nice feeling so i definitely haven't
gotten to play too many moves i would at
least call double explain in my career
but hopefully you enjoyed the examples i
showed and you enjoy this class in the
future